welcome everyone we are so happy to see
such a wonderful turnout for the first
of our Schulman lectures uh for this
semester um I'm just going to say a few
words about the series and about the
course that Lorie Santos my name is
Henry Kohl's I should say that Lorie
Santos and I are our running of which
this series is a part and then I'll turn
things over to Lori to introduce our
speaker so the Schulman lectures are
presented under the opes of the Frankie
program in science and the humanities
which is made possible as many of you
will know by the generosity of Richard
and Barbara Frankie the series is named
after Robert Schulman Sterling professor
ameritus of chemistry molecular
biophysics and biochemistry and Senior
research scientist in Diagnostic
Radiology in recognition of his roles as
a founding fellow of the Whitney and as
an unwavering supporter of the the
integration of the sciences and the
humanities and we couldn't be more
grateful for that this is the the brief
of the Schulman seminar which is the
course that Lori and I are teaching of
which this lecture is a part and our
topic that we've chosen this year and
the topics vary every year is other
Minds as you all know uh the the sort of
um the motivation behind that is that
I'm a historian of psychology and the
human sciences and I study the history
of how psychologists and others tried to
find out what was in the minds of
animals children and other humans in the
late 19th century so the emergence of
experimental psychology and comparative
psychology Lori as it turns out is a
psychologist and she studies the
contents of other Minds including those
of dogs and non-human primates so uh
we've been coming together for a few
weeks with uh 20 students scattered in
the audience to uh I was going to say to
uh debate history versus science but
that is precisely not what we have done
we have synthesized everything from
Darwin to the present week after week on
topics like language morality and
Science and religion and we are now
moving into a series of weeks on
specific animals starting this week with
the topic of dogs so I'll turn it over
to Lori to introduce our
[Applause]
speaker thanks so much it gives me huge
huge pleasure to be able to introduce
Alexandra Horwitz Dr Horowitz got her ba
degree in philosophy at the University
of Pennsylvania and then her Ms and PhD
in cognitive science at the University
of California at San Diego she's
currently an associate professor at
Barnard college at Columbia where she
teaches both canine cognition and
creative non-fiction so she's the
perfect pick for the Schulman lecture
series um at Barnard Dr horoz one runs
the Barnard dog cognition lab where she
studies how dogs make sense of the world
in addition to co-authoring like so many
influential academic papers I couldn't
keep track she's also the author of a
number of popular books um several of
which have made number one on the New
York Times best selling list including
Inside the Mind of a dog what dogs see
smell and know on looking a Walker's
guide to Art of the art of observation
and most recently being a dog following
the dog into a world of smell now when I
was challenged with putting together
this Schulman lecture series with Henry
the first person I wanted to bring out
was Dr Horowitz and it's in part because
she's someone that I've admired for a
very very long time but have not had a
chance to meet um and it was also
because both her scientific scholarship
and the awesome things that she's done
to communicate science to the public
seems like a really perfect fit with
this lecture series um she's this
incredibly rare combination of an a
super super successful scholar some of
her papers are the most influential
papers in the field of K9 cognition and
a true Communicator of science somebody
that can bring these esoteric topics
like thinking in a dog's mind and how
walking affects your senses of the world
and your sense of exploration to a
general lay audience so much so that
she's been able through her books to
bring new students to the science of
canine cognition so when we at our own
lab here at yel we host a summer
internship program for students
interested in K9 cognition and so many
of them who come to the field to be
Scholars themselves started in part
because of one of Dr Horwitz his books
and so I'm super excited to introduce
her and to hear her talk about what is
it like to be a dog I I think what
you'll see is both this wonderful
combination of Science and communication
in action so please join me in welcoming
Dr
[Applause]
Horwitz
wow well that was a very lovely gracious
introduction thank you Lori and thank
you Henry and thank you Tiel I'm
delighted to be uh the first the lead
off other Minds speaker here um it's
perfect because I really got into
science with an interest in other Minds
so framed um I didn't know I was going
to be studying dogs at the time I was
just interested in nonverbal non-human
animals and I wound my way around to
finding out that dogs were the perfect
subject um and then I just got
interested in dogs so it's where I began
and I have a great fondness for the
topic um and I'm still asking this
question to myself all the time what is
it like to be a dog in fact I should
warn you I'm not going to answer the
question today I wish I could instead I
think I'm going to um talk about
approaches to the question different
ways to approach the question in a
particular ways that I have um
approached it I it's fascinating to
study the domestic dog because in some
ways the dog is very familiar probably
they dogs associated with many of you
and at the same time the dog is kind of
paradoxical in its um life with with
humans uh for instance we breed dogs for
their sameness to each other but we
really celebrate their difference from
each other um they're kept in our homes
um and yet they're regularly abandoned
you know we'll name one and yet as a
society we anonymously euthanize
Millions every year we celebrate in some
way their animalism um we might feed
them bones for instance but we also
enforce a kind of airat humanness um
dressing them in sweaters or raincoats
you know holding birthday parties for
them um we cut their ears in some breeds
to look more like wild canids but we
also in breeding have shortened their
faces so that they look more like
primates more like us I'm interested in
one big Paradox which is that we have
this full vocabulary to talk about the
minds of dogs dog owners as dog owners
and people who live with dogs we do what
they're feeling what they know what they
understand The Grudges they might be
holding the pride they might be
experiencing and yet on the other hand
very little of it is empirically
grounded the science of dog cognition as
Laura was saying is is extremely recent
very new so these tensions come out in
my research and the research in my lab
and I want to tell you about the
research that plays into this latter
contrast with the kind of attributions
that we make of dogs on the one hand and
on the other what it might actually be
like to be a dog if you're here you
probably know something about the
history of domestication um you've read
a little bit about the research on that
we know that dogs are um are um come
from a pro a protow wolf of some sort
descended from uh a wolflike animal from
which the common gry wolf and the
domestic dog both descended
independently most of the story of
domestication is told through
archaeology or genetics but I thought
we'd take a slightly different past
talking about the recent history of dogs
and talk about um the history of dogs
representation in art um just briefly to
get you to think about how we've thought
about dogs and how that's changed so
this is a little bit of like an
ethologist at the Museum kind of thing
we're just going to look at the
depiction of art of the dogs in the art
here not at the symbolism of the art and
please excuse me for running rough rough
shot over uh any um art historical
understanding in the ver very earliest
representations of dogs had them
behaving so in cave paintings in this
11th century portrait they were among
humans but acting in some way acting
potentially as um hunters or
guards um or as retrievers for game
and then they began sneaking into
domestic scenes so you can barely see
but you know at the bottom of this
is um a little dog between them
underfoot um or in this rembrand redone
a few years later in a street scene
performing a nice natural behavior
incidentally um in our places of
worship um and in some cases replacing
humans so here's this beautiful TI that
shows Venus being attended to by Cupid
and a loop player and then 3 years later
the loot player has been replaced by a
little
dog and not long after that though they
trotted from the side of the shot the
side of the canvas to be
featured um with us
centrally often mirroring Us in some
way reflecting on
us and then as show breeding began in
the end of the 19th century suddenly
there's a change you know they're alone
um in the picture there's still objects
here objects of fancy the dog fancy and
in some ways these images are like still
lives that include the object that is
the dog but in the 20th century and
actually a little earlier around the
time of Darwin this really changes and
then suddenly what you have is just
portraits of the dog as subject
I love this one as it reflects the dog
potentially reflecting itself to us and
to itself um and then this I feel like
this is when we maybe became interested
of them as individuals and started
talking about their
minds um and then then this kind of
radical transformation
happened it's rare that I get to use
this in an academic talk but in some
ways it's perfect representation of a
lot of the things that we think about
dogs this works in so far as it does
work because we're willing to assume
that dogs could be at some level poker
players and in fact there's even
deception
happening right and so if there's
anything that's about other Minds it's
the ability to manipulate the knowledge
states of others and dogs are doing it
to us in short we
anthropomorphize right we make short
work of the other Minds question and
just say their minds are like ours only
maybe not as smart um anthropomorphisms
might be benign some people think but I
I suggest that they're not um and I have
two reasons why I say that they're not
first because they sometimes have
incredible consequences when we assume
that animals are operating with the same
kind of understanding as we have um for
instance we often assume that animals
and dogs in particular understand right
and wrong
in much of Europe from the latter Middle
Ages to even up to the 18th century
anthropomorphisms to animals in this
kind of context had this extraordinary
effect which was that animals were tried
and punished Often by death in a court
of law for all manner of infractions and
trespasses um against humans and humans
property from from thievery to felonious
intent and often um murder so in this
case for instance this is a 14th this is
EP evans's interesting work scholarship
um 14th century um sa who was being
tried for pushing over and killing a boy
is at that time pigs were running around
in the street and often they'd knock
into children and they would sometimes
hit their heads and die and often they
would be given their own counsel and the
and the their their case would be heard
before a judge and precedent would be
cited and then usually they would be
found guilty and then they'd be executed
in a public display
dressed in human
clothing um with an executioner who has
a special pair of gloves for the
occasion so this is one extreme result
of what happens when we assume that they
have a kind of understanding equivalent
to ours and you could say that we are
beyond that way of thinking about
animals but um hundred years ago Topsy
the elephant some of you might know the
story of Topsy who was
electrocuted publicly for as this says
murdering some of his abusive
trainers um and one could even say that
now when a dog is done something
aggressive or is deemed an aggressor or
potential aggressor we don't even bother
with a trial and we simply execute them
without the even fairness of a
trial that's one possible extreme of
anthropomorphisms in more contemporary
times they make us do things like
this I'm not going to make the case that
dressing your dog as a McDonald's Happy
Meal is in itself um a fundamental
infraction but I do think that assuming
that dogs are going to like the same
kind of celebrations that we do reveals
maybe a little bit of the um emptiness
of our
consideration so with this in mind one
arm of my research has been taking some
of the anthropomorphisms that are
commonly made and examining them looking
at the things we say about dogs and the
attributions we make about dogs and
seeing if they hold up um and I got very
interested at some point in attributions
of emotions to dogs I just grabed these
images off flicker because they're
tagged as sad dog we assume that we can
read dogs emotions well and it's not
just a reading of their face but it's an
assumption that we're knowing something
about their mental state um is are these
dogs sad or are they um resting their
heads on the ground these are proud
dogs I feel like it's very compelling to
make this kind of attribution to the dog
in fact it's hard to turn off the
attribution um it's a natural instinct
we have but could one say alternately
that that dog is not necessarily
experiencing Pride but just holding
their head up high because they have a
really big
stick happy dogs for
instance um or do the edges of their
mouth incline up when they open their
mouth
somewhat so I figur I got very
interested in this these kind of
attributions and I thought well we could
in fact test these do these hold up can
do we have any evidence of this kind of
um these kind of experiences because
Morris at all did a study which showed
for instance that most dog owners
attribute not just primary emotions
which I think everyone would give to um
other mammals but secondary emotions
which are considered a little more
complicated and maybe involve a little
more metacognition in some cases cases
and I got I um did some tests of the
latter two attributions of guilt 34s of
owners believe that their dogs can feel
guilt and
81% think their dogs can feel jealousy
so my question is is that so we start
with
guilt right when I was beginning This
research this fascinating case came up
which prompted some of my methods um in
England at some point
uh there was a dog named Barney ad
Doberman who was perhaps unwisely put in
charge overnight of an invaluable Teddy
Bear
collection this is the scene they found
in the morning heads pulled off arms
legs here and there it was a total
Carnage there was stuffing fluff and
bear bits everywhere the reports said
including ma uh Mabel uh Elvis's prized
teddy bear was uh
disemboweled
um and in fact a lot of the reports were
that this dog Barney felt guilty for
what he had done and perhaps should not
be punished Darwin in fact felt that
there was no doubt that a dog should can
feel shame and so my methodology was
essentially to say well what is it
behaviorally that makes you feel that
the dog is feeling guilty and is guilt
what prompts that behavior in this case
Barney's looking away potentially is
averted gaze is one component of it so
we did a little experiment it was a very
simple experiment which had a 2X two
design and involved dogs and owners
interacting together we went to owner's
homes and we had them work with their
dog we told them to give their dog a
treat and just put it about a yard away
from their dog but tell the dog not to
eat it and then the owners leave the
room and then one of two things
happens the dog is obedient refrains
from eating the treat or the dog is
disobedient and eats the
treat we call the owners back into the
room and if the dog has been obedient
we've asked them to ahead of time greet
their dog happily like they would on
just returning to the room um but if the
dog's been disobedient we ask them to
scold the dog in their usual way and
this was never very severe they were
just say no finin you know what have you
done um and we videotaped the entire
Affair so there were four conditions
essentially often the appropriate thing
happened the dog was obedient and was
greeted or the dog was disobedient and
was scolded
but it's a psychology experiment
sometimes we misled the owners the dog
was disobedient had eaten the treat but
we said oh your dog didn't eat it he was
good and so the owner would come in and
greet the dog and sometimes the dog was
obedient had eat had not eaten the treat
but we said um that they had so the dog
was scolded when the owner returned to
the room we videotaped the dog during
this and we were interested in how much
of a guilty look the dog was expressing
in all of these
conditions so we compiled ideas of what
counted as the guilty look from a couple
of sources Darwin other scientists as
well as owner report on what it was
behaviorally that made them feel like
their dogs experiencing guilt so that
included averting gaze like we saw with
Barney rolling over to show their belly
putting their paw up dropping their tail
in a low wag retreating you know getting
out of there ears down head down and
licking air licking rolling over look
something like this ears down it's a
little hard to see but he looks
naturally guilty and averting
gaze um my lab manager Julie hect did a
little Recreation of the critical scene
here so you can get a sense of what it
looks
like leave it leave it leave it leave
it leave
it come back in she ate
it what did you
do what did you
do poor
gig so what we found is that
guilt whether the dog had eaten the
treat or not did not change the rate of
the guilty look they showed the same
numbers of these behaviors in both those
conditions something did change the rate
of the guilty look it was the owner
Behavior
so when the owners scolded their dogs
that's when they showed the guilty look
much more often than when they were
greeted on the owner return from the
room and interestingly they looked the
most guilty when they were not actually
guilty but they were punished the gigit
case that we just saw scolding led to
the higher rates of the guilty look when
they hadn't eaten the treat than when
they
had so they looked the most guilty when
they were scolded and not when they were
guilty that L makes me think that in
instead of guilt some attribution to
their mental experience as an
explanation for that behavior we instead
have to have another explanation for it
in my case I think the explanation is
that the look is a kind of appeasement
Behavior designed to avoid punishment in
fact it is a very cute look and often
does in um for whatever reason compel
the owner to punish them less severely
than if they hadn't put on the look this
is not a look that dogs do naturally
they learn it over interaction with
their own owners in fact I know a humane
society that after learning about this
research started teaching the dogs in
that they wanted to have adopted they
taught them the guilty look um and sent
them home and the owners thought wow my
dog really is responsive to me and only
later did they they disabuse the owners
that they had taught that look but
essentially we are all teaching that
look in our interaction with our dogs
they get reinforced for giving it to us
note that I'm not saying that dogs don't
feel guilt I'm saying the behavior that
we
think of as showing as evidence for
Guilt is actually
not necessarily so the second thing I
would looked at was that attribution of
jealousy and here it was a little
stickier again I wanted to look at the
what the behavior was that owner's
thought um proved to them that the dog
was feeling jealous and in most cases it
was that the dog believed that a
situation was unfair in other words they
had treats they were given to another
dog they had they were paying attention
to another dog and the their dog comes
in tries to nose in there and get some
of that attention get some of that those
treats and they say they describe that
as jealousy and so in my sense in my
mind and also in some human studies that
notion is predicated on them having a
sense of the fairness or in fact the
unfairness of a situation so that's
where I looked next do they have a sense
of fairness in a lot of literature this
is called a test of inequity aversion
are are animals averse to a situation
which is inequal to them where it's not
equal to them in another animal humans
show uh show inequity aversion if we're
over rewarded for doing a task um we
tend to change our story about our
performance maybe to explain why we're
over rewarded if we're under rewarded
for doing a task not paid as much as
somebody else then then people do things
to moderate their work effort work less
hard to make it match as much as they're
paid so we created an an equal situation
and we wanted to see if dogs were averse
to that so in this case we had a social
situation dogs subjects and a control
dog were approaching two trainers in
turn um and the trainers were really
only asking them to do a simple task
sitting when they asked them so they
would start with their owners their
control is um the black dog here and our
subject is white and they'd approach
each of these trainers and the trainers
would ask them to sit the fair trainer
would reward them both with one tiny
cube of hot
dog and the unfair trainer well there
are two types of unfair trainers but
there was one who gave the control dog
more so there you might be able to see
that there are three bits of hot dog on
the plate for the control dog and only
one for the subject um and there's
another kind of unfair trainer who gives
the control dog nothing at all but still
gives one hot dog to the subject and
then we let the subject choose which of
these trainers after they've been
acclimated to what they deliver they
would like to
approach so in this our first setup was
fair against unfair so this is this are
these are plates representing the number
of treats that each of the trainers give
to our subject and control dog the fair
gives the same the unfair under rewards
the control dog right gives less to the
control dog and we want to see well who
does our subject want to
approach they choose randomly between
these two trainers and it's not that
surprising in some level right they're
given the same amount and they don't
seem to be so worried that the other dog
is getting nothing right no dog ever
complains when getting his dinner have
you fed the cat have you fed the cat yet
they are just concerned with what's in
front of
them then we had this other comparison
which was Fair versus the trainer who
was unfair to them who over rewarded the
other dog so every time they approached
this unfair trainer she gave three times
as much to the other dog as to them that
seems
unfair they highly preferred to approach
the over rewarding trainer the unfair
trainer the one who had treated them
unfairly never given them as much as
they gave to the other dog rather than
approach the fair trainer
they preferred to associate with a
trainer who treated them unfairly but I
wondered what other feature does that
trainer have that the dogs might be
sensitive to rather than their intrinsic
unfairness they do have more
food I think that in this case it's less
a concern with the fairness of the
situation to themselves or to others
than a concern with the resources
available here who has all the goods
what looks like jealous Behavior might
be better described as a sensitivity to
an attention to resources um and I think
it's fair to say that they're Eternal
optimists they keep approaching a
trainer who has not given them food
simply because that trainer has more
resources so in this way I've started to
test some of the attributions that we
make to dogs and it looks like even with
a little bit of probing some of them
aren't going to Bear out in some cas es
we're giving them experiences we're
thinking that they have emotional
experiences in some cases cognitive
experiences um which their behavior
belies so what other approach can we
take um since anthropomorphisms don't
bear scrutiny my interest is in
describing the Dog's Mind by considering
their sensory and cognitive Capac
capacities from their point of view
What's called the umelt of the dog and
this is not my word but this is a word
coined by a German biologist um at the
turn of the 20th century named yakob Van
van UL omel really means I now know just
um world universe or environment um but
he really used it to mean the world of
an animal or even of an individual the
bubble that we all carry around with us
that specially describes the things that
we're sensitive to seeing so it's our
our sensory
capacity what do what's our equipment
that allows us to have the experiences
we do and also our history our
developmental history what are we prone
to notice based on what we've noticed in
the past um and also cognitive capacity
and starting with an omelian view of an
animal you might get a better sense of
what it is like to be that animal so for
instance he drew this picture of what I
have to assume is what a 19th century
sitting room in Germany maybe look like
because this was his image and he
thought well this is a pretty
straightforward image of what we all see
and that we tend to imagine that any
animal entering that room would also see
but then he redrew it from a fly's umelt
where a fly might be only interested in
not the uh the fact of tables but the
scent or odor or warmth coming off of
the food on the table or the warmth
radiating from the light and the rest of
the room is Not Invisible it doesn't
disappear exactly they have the sensory
capacities to notice it but they don't
have a um a functional tone for them
they can't act on it and so they kind of
don't exist and in that way the room is
redrawn from the perspective of the
animal and so he also imagined the dog's
umelt at some level with some amends it
has to do with what's their visual
capacity they're a little bit
nearsighted so they might not be seeing
the things at the top of the room or far
away but also what are the things that
are relevant to them for him it was
things that have a sitting tone places
you might sit um and where food has been
or it has been dropped or where people
might have been and left their Mark um
an odor Rising along the side of a
furniture on the wall that's the thing
that defines the dog's umelt and we
should try to redraw our understanding
of what the dog's experience is with
that umelt in mind so for
dogs we only have to look at their
natural behavior to start to get uh idea
of how to answer what it might be like
to look at a dog uh to be a dog and
their natural behavior involves a lot of
this right all faction sticking their
nose in things in the breeze in your
pocket in your pant leg in each other's
rumps because their world is old factory
now I get my title from uh as a kind of
Illusion to Thomas Nagel the
Philosopher's early paper what is it
like to be a bat um where he after uh
Don Griffin at Rockefeller and his
colleagues had determined that bats
echolocate to navigate uh through a room
and to in fact create a map of the room
of sound something that was mindboggling
to people Nagel thought well what is it
like to be an animal like that since we
don't echolocate can we ever really know
and his answer was no um we can't know
he doesn't think so so but I defy Nagel
I think that we can I think that we can
start to make an imaginative leap into
what it might be like to be a bat or a
dog by taking some measure of their
sensory apparatus what does it mean to
be an animal who is rooted by old
faction for instance um get a sense of
their cognitive capacities and then
redraw the picture from that point of
view so first the thing we need to do is
to explore their ability a little bit to
uh
um their Factory ability to impress upon
us the kind of parameters of smelling
because we are not smelling creatures
although we all have a nose um we really
underutilize it um and it is in some
ways marketly inferior so just a brief
aside to talk about for instance their
equipment we've all known that dogs are
good smellers right we all see working
dogs we know they can smell well but
until recently we didn't know just how
good they are at being smellers and we
still don't even know exactly what it is
that makes them so good but it's
probably some combination of these
things for instance they have many many
more olfactory receptor cells which are
there to snag odor molecules out of the
air so as a comparison we have about 5
million olfactory receptor cells that's
actually a good amount the olfactory
epithelium which holds the receptor
cells is not in the Snell our snout as
it were but it's under the bridge of the
nose between the eyes it's a little
postage stamp size tissue it has about 5
million cells that's pretty good but
dogs have hundreds of millions more so
they have not only many more cells to
receive information but many more types
of receptors which can receive
information receptors as the three color
receptors we have in our eyes allow us
to perceive a Cod Chrome Universe with
just one of those our um ual Universe
would be
diminished they also have what I kind of
like to call a two- noose system there's
the first nose with which you're um
probably familiar and although it looks
ordinary it's not ordinary I mean their
nose is for instance moist for a reason
which I'll get into for a second and
their nostrils have are surrounded by
all sorts of musculature that allows the
nostrils to act independently so by
getting a different um odor picture from
each nostril they can have a uh stereo
old faction a stereo way of smelling the
world um there's also fascinating
research that shows that they use their
nostrils differentially when smelling
new sources so they start if you're ever
close enough to a dog smelling you to
examine notice that they might start
smelling you with a right nostril first
and then if you're um friendly or
familiar then they start using their
left nostril but if you're for instance
a
veterinarian um with who's been sweating
a lot that's the substance of the
researchers used something that was
potentially aversive to a dog then they
stay sniffing with their right nostril
so they're using their nostrils in an
important way that's the first nose but
they have another nose too that a lot of
other non-human animals have it's called
a vomo nasal organ and it's these
fluid-filled Sachs that's beneath the
nasal septum that divides the nose and
above the roof of the
mouth and it's able to detect low
molecular
weight uh water soluble molecules ones
that are nonvolatile not the things that
are flying in the air that we can smell
but ones that have to be absorbed in
order to be it detected um things like
pheromones they might have heard about
pheromones there's a lot of research
that shows that hormones like pheromones
which are used to give information for
instance about sexual status of other
members of the species are detectable by
Von nasal organ you have to have a mo
moist nose for that to act as a
conveyance of some of the information to
the varal nasal
organ the snout of their nose is not
trivial either so they actually if you
look at a cross-section of their nose
these turbinate bones as they call as
they're called are throughout it almost
looks like a slice of brain um and this
allows air that's being sniffed in to go
down an elaborate roller coaster ride
where it's humidified it's warmed um
it's filtered for any particles stray
particles um and in fact some of the uh
turbonet are lined with epithelial
tissue so the dog can start taking apart
the odor sort of
spectrographically before it even
reaches the main epithelium tissue by
contrast our um turbinate bones look
like that we have three so our noses are
kind of blunt instruments Kitty rides
compared to the uh roller coaster that
is the dog's nose
they also have two different dedicated
roots for sniffing so you know very well
that if you want to get a smell out of
your nose you have to do one thing you
exhale it right because the air that
comes in has one root it will hit your
epithelial tissue or not and if you want
it to come out you exhale through your
nose but dogs are seeing the world
through their nose so they don't want to
Exhale it out like closing your eyes
between seeing Vistas so instead they
have a dedicated rote one red rot that
goes where air flow goes right to the uh
olfactory epithelial tissue to be
smelled and another that goes to the
lungs for regular
respiration dogs sniff better than we do
too before I started this research I
didn't know that you could be a better
or worse sniffer but you can and we're
worse um in a couple of ways one is that
we sniff pretty slowly kind of
laconically if you take a sniff now we
we will you sniff please we do that in
about one and a half seconds dogs are
typically taking about five to seven
sniffs a second that just allows for a
lot more odor pictures of the
world um and again we go in and out the
same nostril that seems like a natural
way to sniff but researchers who have
studied the air flow um the fluid
dynamics of the air around the dog's
nose have discovered that expired air
exhaled air is sent out not through the
main part of the nostrils but through
the side slits of the side of their nose
and what this does is allow for
simultaneous sniffing and expiring a
kind of circular breathing not only that
but that expired air if you notice a
dog's nose near a surface will send up
what they call a turbulent canine
nostril air jet like a puff of air that
actually will hurry more odor molecules
into the nose of the dog
so that all describes the commitment of
the sensor equipment to smelling and
then what it has allowed them to do well
for instance a tracking dog if we look
at tracking dogs performance they're
asked to follow the odor of someone who
has departed sometime prior with the
evidence with solely evidence um of all
Factory nature if we were asked to tell
where this person went we could there's
visual sufficient Visual Evidence
but what if that Visual Evidence is
compromised because the waves come and
wash over it well the tracking dog can
still tell which way that person is gone
and that's because the tracking dog is
able to distinguish the concentration of
odor the person's odor left in their
footstep as we all leave odor in our
footsteps pushed through our shoe from
our foot between the first first and
fifth footstep the odor concentration is
sufficiently different for the tracking
dog to tell that's about 2 seconds worth
and then that's the way the dog
determines directionality I think that
if we look at this experientially what
is it like to be a dog who is sensitive
to minute differences in concentration
of odor that it actually is going to
recreate not only a picture of um where
people have been but actually recreates
an understanding of time itself for in
some ways if you look at the weaker OD
odors they are the older
odors and the stronger odors are the
newer odors so as you leave the house
you and your dog the dog is smelling the
past what has happened outside underfoot
on odors on the ground or a breeze that
comes around the corner might bring
information about someone who you do not
see yet who has not arrived because
their odor is scent on the W on the Wind
to the waiting dog's nostril so the
moment of now for dog is kind of rubber
banded to include a little bit of the
past and a little bit of the future in
it so this has very much changed the way
I have looked at dogs
experimentally I realize not only we
have to control for odors in the room
because that's a salian component of
what dogs are experiencing in the lab
but also we might start look at some of
these cognitive studies
and ask them in an all Factory way and
so I'll tell you briefly about my most
recent experiment um in that
regard there is the question in
comparative psychology of
self-recognition of this component of
the dog's mind or any other animal's
mind do does the animal know that it is
themsel in a mirror or in fact do they
have a sense of self at all do they
recognize that they are a self different
from other self eles um as we look in
the mirror and see ourselves and maybe
notice a hair that is out of place and
work to correct that you know would they
this question was asked many years ago
by a primatologist named Gordon Gallup
as he um was shaving in the mirror as I
understand it and he wondered if his
chimpanzees would in fact recognized
themselves looked in look if they saw
themselves in the mirror as well and so
what did he do he put a mirror in the
enclosures of the
chimpanzees what did they do well first
they attacked the mirror because there's
another chimpanzee who suddenly entered
their enclosure and and furthermore it's
one who's attacking them but they very
quickly learned that it was not another
ape um and they started to use the
mirrors in this kind of way to examine
themselves to look at parts of
themselves they never saw before their
rump you know inside their mouth to make
faces at this mirror and see themselves
making faces back but he was interested
in that very much so but thought it
doesn't actually show evidence that
they're seeing that as themselves it
shows evidence that they've learned to
use the mirror as a thing that a
manipulandum that they can make do
things make show certain types of
pictures so he designed What's called
the mirror self-recognition test um
where he surreptitiously marked his
chimpanzees on the forehead with an
odorless red dye and the next time they
saw themselves in the mirror he looked
at them what did they do and what the
chimpanzees did was they put up their
front hands and touched the Mark just as
we would do they passed this mirror
self- recognition test so since that
time this test has been uh revised and
tried with a lot of other species
including Dolphins who have been marked
Ong their body and show unusual
movements since they don't have hands
which which they can touch the marks in
front of the mirror to ostensibly
examine it one elephant named happy has
passed this test uh European magpies
have passed the test I just saw uh a
report coming up here that um in
addition to pigeons and other animals
who've been trained to pass a test there
was a study with Reese's macca who fail
the test typically training them to pass
the test um
what about dogs do they pass the test no
they do not they don't seem to care
about their image in the
mirror maybe not that surprising in some
ways right their dog doesn't seem
concerned with their own apparent
they're not grooming animals there are a
lot of good explanations for why they
might not be concerned they certainly
can visually appreciate the mirror they
can use the mirror to get information so
in some ways they understand the mirror
or they can interpret the stimulus um
but they're not passing the
test I think the punchline is this what
about if the mirror smelled what if the
mirror smelled of them if the image they
saw in the mirror were more suited to
their umelt they're not visual creatures
they're not concerned with the mark on
their paw except in so far as it might
taste
good um let's look at their natural
behavior because of this they do that
they're investigating odors all the time
now they're usually odors of other dogs
but these are odors that have elements
that would be indic indicative of who
the dogs are sort of signature mixes
which are smellable and detectable by
the vroon nasal
organ so prompted by this I set out to
design essentially um an old factory
mirror to see if dogs use smell to
recognize
themselves as they do to recognize
others so I'm happy to say I don't have
an actual mirror that smells that will
reflect your smell because that might be
horrifying but instead what we did is we
use the same medium that dogs use to
communicate information about themselves
to others which is their urine we asked
owners to collect a small amount of
their dog's urine and then we presented
it to them in a novel context in a
canister as well as presenting to them
um a little bit of the urine of an
unknown dog and as well as
presenting something analogous to mon A
Perfect Analogy um to be fair to their
image marked so the um their own urine
but marked with another odorous
substance um an experimenter would draw
their attention to the canisters and
then they were allowed to examine them
at lib and we were basically testing
investigation time how long did they
spend
sniffing um so I thought i' I'd this
isn't also not answering what it's like
to be a dog but it's sort of what is it
like to be a dog researcher um this is I
have a little bit of a cut of some of
our subjects participating so you can
see what it's
[Music]
like look at that was
this
okay
okay very exhaustive
search
there's always an outlier
this is our
outlier in fact I sped up the tape a
little bit so because she spent so long
on
it and that is
why so again we were looking at how long
do they sniff the P sorry let me move to
the next
slide and we did a couple of different
comparisons first we did that comparison
of their own odor and odor of another
dog and what we found is that they spend
significantly longer sniffing the odor
of the other dog that's nice because
it's evidence that we that we brought
into the lab the behavior that we see in
the world that they're going to spend
more time sniffing others markings and
not as much time if any going back and
checking their
own and then we compared how they how
long they spent investigating themselves
and themselves marked and again they
spent more time investigating the odor
of themselves when it was marked we also
compared that to a control where it was
just the marked smell to make sure that
it wasn't just a fascinating smell for
them and they don't spend any longer in
fact slightly less investigating the
smell by itself than their own urine
marked with that
smell so what I want to say based on
this is that although the mirror
self-recognition test is not a perfect
test this is not a perfect analog of it
but at some level when we start to
consider the dog from an Al Factory
point of view we can see that we might
be able to get evidence that they're
recognizing their own odor as something
like themselves that kind of Entry to
The elusive sense of self which is so
hard to experimentally investigate with
nonverbal
others okay that's all I have for you I
think the aim of science ific inquiry
into others Minds should take that umel
in perspective and so what is it like to
be the animal it seems to me you have to
start with that animal's sensory and
cognitive equipment uh ask and that's
your way of asking them and they will
answer thank you very
much
and I am happy to take
questions of which I know there are more
than zero yes right in the
middle hang on hang
on yes
great thanks um yes so you mentioned way
at the beginning of the lecture that
dogs make the perfect subject so why why
would you say that that's the case well
in my case when I was interested in
investigating mind um the very first
study that I did was about play was I
was interested in this theoretical
notion theory of mind which as humans we
all develop most normally developing
people develop which is ability to think
about oneself and others um and know
that others minds are different from
one's own and one of the contexts in
which we might learn some of this is in
play um and
uh I was casting about as a graduate
student for a species to study which
played because I wanted to look at a
natural behavior to see a natural
context in which this metacognitive
ability might emerge um and I looked at
a lot of primates who play but certainly
more often when they're juveniles and
less often when they're adults and also
can disappear from View and play out of
view of you and meanwhile I was I had a
dog and I was taking her three times a
day to the park and it took me about 6
months cuz I was an upo graduate student
to realize like I had a subject here who
was playing all the time engaged in
Social play and that's when I started
taping dogs so for some things I think
their
ubiquity and um their so for instance
you know to get dogs to come into the
dog lab um is not difficult we don't
have to go find the dogs owners bring
their dogs they come with them and
happily bring their dogs which is
fantastic so in some ways they're great
subject for the beginnings of experiment
of observation or experimental inquiry
into mind they're not the easiest one
and they certainly weren't looked at for
a long time I think partly because they
are
domesticated um and people were less
interested in domesticated animals and
some and some may still be that in some
way they're adulterated that they're not
really true minds you know but it seems
to me they are an even more interesting
case if we're interested in
extrapolating from human cognition and
to talk about non-humans because they
are the the result of selective breeding
by this Mind by the human mind so they
bear two you know the results of natural
selection and of artificial selection
and that's
fascinating
yeah um okay so I my question is about
sort of the guilt uh sure question um I
guess uh you know I I normally associate
guilt with doing something wrong um and
in this case it was just uh either
eating or not eating a a treat so I'm
wondering and I sort of think of guilt
as arising from kind of sympathy or the
ability to empathize and think I don't I
wouldn't want that to happen to me or
something right um in other words like
have you thought of maybe following that
up with like a some a more serious
infraction right exactly right no I
haven't although that's an interesting
idea but the exactly the way you phrase
what guilt involves makes it seem to me
a much less likelier emotion that we
could attribute to dogs right that a lot
of not only is our guilt often not
behaviorally obvious to begin with but
in other words you just feel internally
the guilt but what exactly prompts it
and and it's has to do with uh our
inculturation as humans you know we
learn how to be guilty um and it seems
less likely that that would be something
that that uh canids would experience but
I think that would be really fascinating
to see I don't know what greater
infraction dogs in a general purpose way
do I mean eating they're lot I guess
there actually I can think of lots of
misbehavior there are lots of complaints
based on you know dog misbehavior that
maybe we could try to recreate um but
surprisingly in this case dogs still had
a reaction I think that's also the kind
of takeaway they had differential
reaction in different in different
settings um and so they were noticing
differences in those settings uh it's
just that the difference they noted was
not the one that we think they should
notice
yeah so in EM in emotional psychology
and emotion psychology uh they there's
like this divide between like basal
emotions like fear and happiness versus
the more socially tinged emotions that
we label guilt shame and I'm wondering
have you I know you looked at guilt and
jealousy because of your survey and like
seeing that the owners like said oh I'm
sure I can like see this but has your
lab also investigated like the more
basil emotions primary emotions they
don't require necessarily the owner and
I think that we haven't but I think
neurologically most people would Ascent
that um non-human mammals experience
basic emotions right that there's
nothing sufficiently different in their
neural setup that we and and certainly
behavior that correlates with it um
approaching things which give them
pleasure repeatedly and avoiding things
you know which make them sad or upset or
however you want to describe a
distancing the emotion that might
correlate to a distancing um Behavior so
I feel like that's pretty much agreed
not entirely but pretty much agreed upon
and it's these secondary emotions more
complicated emotions that are still up
for
grabs
yes
um when you have uh two dogs together
yeah and you pet one of them exclusively
the other dog often gets agitated yes is
that a form of jealousy that's thank you
for your choice of words there yes um
well that's exactly this experience that
leads people um at least in our survey
to attribute jealousy to their dogs
exactly that you're giving attention to
one dog or you're dolling out treats
resources to one dog and the other dog
gets agitated tries to move between you
and the other dog whines barks otherwise
tries to do attention getting behaviors
right so that's what is being described
as jealousy and in my experiment what I
what I felt like is for that to be
jealousy in the way that we think of
jealousy which is I think the important
thing to start with here I mean we're
trying to decide about dogs do they have
experiences mental experiences which
match our own in these ways the way we
think about jealousy it has to do with
it's predicated on some understanding of
fairness of and the and the ultimate
unfairness of that situation where
you're giving all the attention to one
dog so if they're not actually so
concerned about fairness at least not in
the way that we seem to be or not
perceiving it as the most Salient
attribute of what's Happening then I
think one can question whether jealousy
is the best explanation for their
behavior yes way in the back oh Sor upst
upstairs sorry and then I'll go down
yeah
beens
yeah training these any no I mean I know
researchers who do the training of
diabetic alert dogs and as well as are
trying to train cancer detection dogs
and there are hypoglycemia um and Di um
alert dogs and even some seizure
detection dogs I haven't been involved
in their training what's it's wonderful
and fascinating training it is all
Factory training you know I mean
basically they're trained on um the odor
of blood sugar um which is another way
that I think that trying to get in the
mind mind of the dog the umelt of the
dog is a little bit mindboggling because
we don't think typically of blood sugar
levels having a certain odor but it is
discriminable by dogs and they're highly
reliable at doing it and I'd say it's a
fantastic that you're going to have such
a dog and I think the only thing is if
you're healthy then the dog gets no um
reward for finding
out that your blood sugar is off the
charts so you have to you know
occasionally test them with a stimulus
that um that that you can reward them
for I'm wonder if I'm in a room with
other diabetics What's happen well
that's fascinating right but they're
going to have a relationship with you
and you're going to be the one who's who
they're uh kind of been trained on and
attentive to but right as with all
working dogs do they not notice the
sensory environment that they're in or
they almost certainly do but when
they're working and they form a very
strong delineation between working time
and non-working time they're really
focused on their work exclusively and
you and you will be your dog's
work yeah so right
there
person also because
thinks
to what audience you know I mean anyone
who's interested in dogs actually I feel
like most dog owners are naturally
curious not only do we come with a
vocabulary immediately that we want to
put on the dogs but we want to have the
answers to the questions about who the
dogs are we want to be able to State
what their personality is like you know
whether they're clever or not how they
would perform in certain settings we
want to be able to predict their
behavior so dog owners are um a very
receptive audience and as you know as a
dog someone who lives with dogs myself I
know that it my research reflects back
on how I interact with them in the
academic world it's slightly different I
it is um but partly while Lori has
established an amazing lab here if you
haven't visited did it with your dog you
should um and but this is very recent
work and as I and there was when I was a
graduate student just anecdotally and I
wanted to study dogs I had to argue for
it um and I uh a lot of people were
definitely not convinced that I should
be able to do a dissertation or defend
or pass a defense based on doing dog
research um because um just because of
historically how we've considered dogs
not certainly behaviorally there's been
a lot of research looking at dogs from
for the
last 50 years maybe 130 years at least
but but not cognitively not with making
attributions to their minds so it's a
slightly different crowd um and a
slightly different reception but it's
that's somewhat changing when we show
novel methods for investigating
cognition that can come up uh in
comparative psychological world just as
we've done with non-human primates and
ulates and now farm animals as well
right I think they're kind of benefiting
from an interest in in the the
domesticated animals cognition now
there's a lot of farm domesticated
animal cognition work coming out too
which is amazing uh we have one right
here which is easy for me so okay
good I was um impressed by your overview
of the depiction of dogs in
artwork so I want to ask you a very
non-scientific question I'm interested
in your view of when you think dogs as
depicted in cartoons like Tom and Jerry
are hopelessly
anthropomorphized and another thing that
came into my mind when you showed the
dog trashing the place was this the
silly movie with Owen Wilson and
Jennifer andon I think it was called
Marley and Me I I'm just interested bad
The Bad Dog right yeah I'm just
interested in your your view of that
that yeah well as a matter of fact
thanks for your question that most
depiction of dogs uh in movies mov um in
cartoons certainly is is highly
anthropomorphic in fact animators not
just dogs dogs are not the only ones
subject to this but animators you know
intentionally anthropomorphize their
subjects and and as somebody with a
young child I now am reminded that when
you look at m a reading material for
young children it's almost exclusively
animals talking to each other who we
talk talk to about that person is saying
that and they're having exactly the
sentiments that we're having but they're
all
animals they don't have animal character
characteristics particularly and so I
think yeah that's riding off of the fact
that it is a we have a natural tendency
to anthropomorphize it didn't come up
with domestication that we started
anthropomorphizing it's in fact we've
been people have been scolding us for
anthropomorphizing for thousands of
years because initially the
anthropomorphisms were um uh of the Gods
right that Gods might be in Mortal form
and that was censored um but then to
predict weather you know we say that a
wind is
angry um at us uh inanimate objects to
kind of understand the behavior the
movement of the Seas we've attributed
human characteristics to those so we've
been doing it forever I think it's quite
a natural tendency and cartoons take
advantage of that fully
yeah yes right
there popular mind it's always said that
some breeds of dogs are more intelligent
than others they learn faster or they
can understand more complex cognitively
complex situations so I wondered how
many of your interesting observations
are generalizable across breeds and if
you particular breeds as your subject
right well I I haven't and in fact
because there is a lot of groundwork
that could be done in in dog cognition
before we start narrowing in on
interesting questions like that a lot of
the work that's been done out there has
been of just any breed right the idea is
to make some statement about dogs per se
not about Golden Retrievers exactly um
but there's a little bit of work in that
direction but to your point to your to
your premise of the question too I very
much um question talking about different
dogs as having different intelligence or
at least a ranking of intelligence from
the smartest to the least smart right I
mean it's certainly the case that there
are some dogs like say bordic Coles who
might perform high on in these
intelligence scales who are extremely
proficient at their jobs right of
hurting but they're horrible at doing
other things like being a calm dog who
sits and waits for you all day by
themselves at home doing nothing you
know whereas some of the other dogs who
are really
nonresponsive to problem solving tasks
and so forth um are really good at
something else because when they are
faced with a problem
they look toward their owner the tool
who can solve the problem for them well
that's kind of considered stupid because
they don't persist at the problem but
it's actually in another way really
smart because the owner does open the
refrigerator we solve that problem for
them every day you know and so what
counts as smart and if you said what
counts as smart in the uh living among
humans I would say it's some of the dogs
who are sometimes ranked lowest on those
intelligence scales right um
but it it would nonetheless it would be
fascinating with many of these studies
to look at single breeds and when I did
play research I was fascinated by the
fact that um as anecdotally reported
lots of same breed dogs seem to play
with each other differently than they
did with different breeds so you'd have
suddenly a lot of wine rers who were
great doing great Rough and Tumble play
with each other and I I'm curious and
I've not investigated it yet but whether
there's something about the signals that
they're reading from each other that
allows them to be um more rambunctious
without any um repercussion something
like that so it would be fascinating
yeah about seeing ey I haven't studied
seeing eye dogs good population but then
again you know they're also committed to
their project and so you're not going to
get the kind of natural dog behavior
which you'd like to get when you are
sampling a dog and trying to generalize
there from there was something right up
front
yeah so um
so a few of us here uh we go to Southern
Connecticut State University and right
now um we're going uh right now we're
taking a few courses on sort of the
progression of the sense of the self
through history and a human perspective
but um when you were talking about how
they how dogs look they see themselves
through their sense of smell I was going
um do you think that dogs um have the
same s like do they have the same sense
of self through through their ability to
smell versus through humans way of
seeing themselves visually is it them uh
good question right I well almost
certainly I doubt that it's identical
right our sense of self is caught up in
not just an individual sense and not
just an autobiographical sense of myself
through time but a cultural sense of how
we Define self in the culture we're in
which is different in non-western
cultures and in Western cultures for
instance so there's that that's all in
my sense of self um and then there
individual differences but so to change
modality on us I think probably does
change that and and you don't have the
same kind of cultural influences in
populations of dogs of necessity as you
do in in the human population so that
would change as well I think at base all
I could possibly be talking about by
talking about sense of self with both
species groups is just thinking about
themselves as different from others
right so distinguishing themselves
not necessarily in a ruminative
thoughtful way but um in terms of having
a kind of understanding of themselves
like I did that in the past and I'm
going to do this and and someone else
did or didn't do those things with me so
sort of the distinction of oneself and
others in the world and I think that's
maybe the minimal way we could Define
self yes there's in the middle and the
back I have you running around Henry
sorry
hi thanks if I can speak from a humani
perspective I was really interested with
the opening with the um uh the sort of
cultural and historical construction of
the idea of a dog in relation to humans
yeah and I think what was quite
interesting by the medieval sort of mock
Trials of animals it comes out of a sort
of theological understanding of animals
not having a soul yes um and uh that's
very interesting I'm a theologians is a
very interesting idea about what happens
if a dog comes and eats the consecrated
host and runs away from the altar yeah
have have they received the body of
Christ or not you know it's a very sort
of tricky theological canon law question
which I'm not sure I could answer if
anybody asked me um but I'm just
wondering whether um in the move to uh
having animals painted as portrait
portraits of the animals it comes around
at a time when um uh the idea of humans
having a soul has also diminished and
therefore the uh the dogs as were their
as you were position in the world can be
equal to ours because diminished and so
they're they're enhanced but we sort of
meet part way a little bit something
like that yeah because I think I think
that's that so even though they have the
mock trials in the medieval period
because they don't have a soul then it
doesn't really ultimately makes no
difference whether they Comm a crime or
not but in the sort of in our era it
might have more of a import because of
our ambiguity about human souls and
salvation that's fascinating I don't
know I and I certainly has I haven't in
I haven't ever traced the you know the
trajectory of uh how we've thought about
animal Souls over over time but I think
you're right certainly culturally today
that our our willingness to attribute
having souls to others to which is
probably not so distant from our
willingness to attribute them to
especially the animals we keep in our
homes Maybe not maybe they are still a
uh preserved class though so it would be
dogs and cats or maybe some other
domestic animals but I wonder if if you
stepped a little bit outside of that to
the cat to the pigs who were routinely
tried if they would be granted the same
uh level um but fascinating
thanks um right way in the back under
the
light uh I've been wondering about uh
the power of smell and potentially in
training dogs or in helping dogs like
thinking about if smell is so powerful
to them like you know even in working
with word dogs we're always using food
or touch or attention but should we be
thinking about smell in terms of calming
dogs or even in training dogs or
thinking about how to how to work with
dogs should we be using smell more as as
humans oh it's interesting question yeah
I think that smell might not be
intrinsically rewarding so if you're
doing a specific rewarding task um the
smell itself so on its own is probably
not rewarding I mean I imagine that for
smell we try to picture what it's like
to be a smelling creature it's just
information about it's just information
just the way that I have a lot of visual
information in this room and I'm I'm not
necessarily rewarded by it so I don't
think it would be a good specific reward
but I think it is important to be
conscious of the potential smells in the
environment in a training environment or
even in your home environment right I
mean given that we all carry a lot of
smells with us even the very clean Among
Us is just a great bubble of smell to
the dog you know smells that we exude
when we're in a training context uh if
we're stressed just as behaviorally that
can go down the leash to the dog maybe
the smell can also make the dog anxious
so I haven't seen any research looking
into that but I would love to see kind
of if there's a contagious emotional
reaction probably smell mediated that
interferes with
training thanks
so dress down here oh then I'm going to
get to the other side of the room been
neglecting I'm sorry who was it uh I'm
three
in so when I told my wife that I was
coming to hear you she said are you
going to ask her about midnight and the
very strange thing she does and you've
almost demanded that I do so I will um
so midnight is a 10-year-old black lab
who's lived with us for eight months and
I was apparently entirely unaware of
what my wife regards as a very strange
habit I wonder if you've encountered it
before but you're showing us the
experiment of the dog smelling the pee
prompts this so apparently uh
unbeknownst to me midnight goes out in
the world smells where she herself has
peed and then smells herself smell goes
and smells her rump or her under her ex
belly exactly Compares notes huh I
haven't ever heard about that might be a
n of one no I have never heard about
that type of behavior that's that's
interesting right I can tell my wife she
has an exceptional
dog she'll be very pleased much yes um
over on this
side Henry choice I bought and read two
of your books thank you that's very nice
of
you
yeah the city pound city has the largest
pound in
conne
write your books very terrific I have
one simple yes
or that's what you
think
and uhuh
does well certainly a lot of tenacity
well that's not a yes or no question is
it
that's certainly a lot of tenacity by
you for you right it's not trivially
easy to get your dog to pee and poo on
on command and location so H
congratulations to you for doing that
yes the dog if you are reinforcing them
correctly it's easy for them to do that
it's just that it's often we do not have
the patience and fortitude to persist
with the training such that they will
understand what we're asking asking of
them and be able to do it so good job
thank you yes behind
her hi um so I've been thinking a lot
about um kind of 19th century debates
about the arbitrary nature of animal
taxonomy um and so kind of kind of
Beyond um dogs having a sense of
individual self um do dogs have any
sense of like a group of dogs either in
relation to um humans or other animals
or like among breeds or is that
something that we project onto by a
group of dogs do you mean what do you
mean by a group of dogs like that's the
yeah like those are all dogs yeah kind
of like ontological understanding of
like things that are dogs well there's
some science that potentially could uh
address that which is that dogs are able
to
recognize um and discriminate dog from
non-dog faces right they do even there's
a face of a a goat looks very much like
a dog even seeing a picture dogs are if
they're trained to um push the screen
when they see a dog face they don't push
the screen when they see the Goat Face
so they have a sense of
dogness um in in much the way that we do
at some level breeds I don't know but
there might be an an reflex of kind of
instinctive understanding of um int
intro breeds other members of their own
breed based on similar body mapping but
that's the hypothesis I don't know for
sure good question
thanks um from what I understand a lot
of the discoveries for human psychology
and abnormal psychology have kind of
come from when things have gone arai and
gone wrong um has there been any
Research into the cognitive abilities of
dogs through dogs that have experienced
some kind of
trauma oh fascinating right there's the
abnormal Cog dog abnormal dog cognition
um right we h I
don't I don't know about that you know
Noah the only dogs that have really come
so most of the studies are you know
there are naturalistic observations
where we go out in the world and study
dogs behaving those so those are not
exceptional we're just looking at
samples there are experimental studies
which are often comparative
psychologically driven where you ask for
people to people in their dogs to come
in and you give them an experimental
test but there too you're looking for a
sample and there only been a couple of
cases where there's some dog out in the
world that kind of draws the cognitive
researchers to them and it's usually for
their exceptional behaviors not for
their abnormal behaviors um like um I'm
thinking of Rico who was a border colag
who Julian
Kaminsky heard from their owners that
this is a border col knew 200 words you
know and she went and sort of
investigated that one dog and there have
been some others but I haven't heard of
the kind of instead we kind of recast
those dogs as um sort of misbehaving
dogs you know as opposed to dogs who
have like interestingly different
cognition but now that you ask that I
think we should be looking for them we
have one back here yeah um so in your
guilt study um you found that you know
it wasn't necessarily that God that uh
dogs were feeling guilt per se but more
so uh um an aversion to their owner's
you know behavior and scolding them yeah
um now if we apply that to like human uh
behavior and emotion how how much um can
we say that like humans actually
experience guilt um or is it more so a
aversion or a tactic to minimalize um
you know any aive results right ex yeah
it's a great question I think a lot of
our learning of of of how to of what to
label and kind of how to behave in
certain circumstances that we then call
our secondary emotions or identify as
our secondary emotions we're probably
learned through associative learning you
know when you do something and you're
punished for that you learn that that
was the wrong something that you
shouldn't be doing and then you might
start to have anticipatory feelings of
guilt that there was something wrong
based on that and we learn that through
a kind of conditioning you know learning
like a dog might learn it right now an
emotions researcher would have a lot
more to say then of what develops there
from which I don't know if it develops
in dogs right we have to be agnostic
about it so they're The Roots split but
I do think that they have a common they
have uh a common history in the
development of the individual yeah yeah
right next to
you thanks so much for the great talk I
actually had the same question as the
the last person but I'm wondering how
you're really thinking about the dog
human relationship in your science and
given that that's such a strong
component of these dogs lives how is
that shaping Behavior how are you
factoring that
in uh well in different studies
differently right um so at the very base
level when you deal with dogs you have
to their natural environment is the
anthropogenic environment in which we
found ourselves their natural
environment is with humans there aren't
um domestic dogs who are out there
living on their own outside of human
societies particularly um so you have to
kind of imagine that it's this setting
in which we should consider them as
naturally behaving that said owners can
really influence the behavior of their
dogs so in any experimental setting one
has to limit control very much what the
owner can do to potentially cue the dog
about how to behave because the owner
going into an experiment has a lot of
thoughts about how they should behave or
their dog should behave kind of as their
proxy to be to behave well um and so you
have to stop limit their queuing and
that often means um having the owner
present because having the owner
separate is itself a problem right the
dog will then want to just get to the
own return to the owner maybe not want
to participate in your task um but
limiting the number of things they can
do in the in the cues I can give to the
dogs often we
um ask the owner to do a distractor task
a which is just a distraction for the
owner so for instance in the ill Factory
mirror task where we the owners started
out holding their dogs and then we when
the experimenter turns her back they're
supposed to release their dogs um but we
don't want the owner to have any feeling
like uh I want to just subtly point that
the dog should go one way or another
based on their hypothesis of where the
dog should go um so we have them instead
doing another task they're responsible
for counting the number of times the dog
is looking back at them and at the end
their experience of that event was like
five times my dog looked back at me five
times right so they so that's one way
that you can kind of block it um in
other cases you're interested in the
human dog Dynamic per se you know that's
the thing we study so one of my other
lines of research which has to do with
play we looked at human
um dog play uh and there we want the
human to be involved and however they
want to be involved and playing with the
dog and we're coding both human and dog
behavior in that case thanks
yeah there's a mic right behind you hold
on yeah um I understand in um in humans
that super taster are more likely to be
women and what are more like super
tasters yes and I wondered if you noted
any differences in your research between
male and female dogs super smellers in
their ability to either in their
interest in smelling or their ability to
send detect well so we haven't done any
studies it's a great question of um
individual variability in smell so we're
because we're not doing threshold
detection tasks not my research isn't
like how how little of a substance can
they detect all the substances in the
couple of studies I've done where we
present them and odorant stimulus it's
detectable you know sometimes it's even
detectable by us so it's not a question
of being good enough to smell it at all
um but there still could be really large
individual differences between you're
right and which we haven't looked at at
all and we haven't looked at a gender
difference either and what we only thing
we do know about is that we had all um
sper neuter dogs so we don't have any um
female dogs who were going hormonally
through something which might change
their sense of smell which is one of the
hypothesized reasons for why some women
are better smellers for instance which
women are on the whole considered better
smellers than men um and it's considered
related to the hormones so we haven't
looked at it it's a good question uh
we're just starting we we feel like
we're just getting started on this I
mean the question mark at the end of my
title slide is really a pronounced
question mark we we really don't know
that much about dog cognition yet one
more question okay one more question you
right
[Laughter]
there
hi um so I have a question that's like
specific to the um guilt study so you
found that there's a difference in um
guilty reaction when the dog um actually
did not eat versus when they did and I'm
wondering when I think what's it like to
be a dog is there some sort of mental
representation of right and wrong even
if that's not connected to guilt as in I
did what I was supposed to do yeah I'm
being scolded so there's
um a more of a reaction so basically
what do you think are the implications
of that difference between whether they
had or had not eaten and still receive
scolding yeah it's a good point so
that's that final observation was that
in the case where they were not guilty
but they were scolded so the most unfair
case to them really um they looked the
most guilty um and I think that the
implication is that there are
internalizing that there is a right and
wrong scenario now what they consider
the right or wrong thing is probably not
as clearcut as it is for us we assigned
them a task and there was a clear right
and a clear wrong um for the dog is it
like that is it so defined probably not
but I think that is a little bit um
provocative that there might be some
understanding and certainly any any dog
who is a well-b behaving dog is
essentially a dog who has learned the
rules for Behavior around you right and
one could say there are right ways to
behave in certain contexts that's what a
well- behaved dog or trained dog has
done has learned and that there are
wrong ways and so yes at some level
right they might be understanding that
right or wrong yep all right well please
join me in thanking Dr Horowitz for
wonderful
talk thank
you and
[Music]
uh